Oi Leute, was wird gekauft? Jede Menge Zeug. Ich weiß auch nicht.
Gibt es neuen Rechner? Nein, es gibt
alle möglichen Sachen. Ich habe mir gedacht,
also ich habe gerade da gesessen so ohne Stream und habe bei Amazon Dinger zusammen geklickt, habe ich mir gedacht, weißt du was, wir haben schon
lange keinen, wir suchen uns Dinger zusammen raus und ich kaufe mir was. Stream gemacht.
Es ist 19.30 Uhr, ist schon ein bisschen später.
Kegg Bros. Übelst random Mischung. Ich brauche ein paar Technik Sachen, ich brauche Sachen fürs
Fahrrad, ich brauche Sachen für den Rasierer, ich brauche Sachen für die Katze, ich brauche T-Shirts,
alles mögliche. Ich brauche wahrscheinlich eine neue Waage und da brauche ich eine,
die ich gescheit wieder per Bluetooth auslesen kann, weil meine Mi Scale hat einen Anzeigefehler
und das sackt. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das ausdrücken soll. Vielleicht hole ich mir auch
wieder einfach eine Mi Scale. Die waren nicht so teuer und lassen sich super per Bluetooth auslesen.
Waage mit Body Fat. Theoretisch hat die Waage sogar Body Fat Messgram, aber das benutze ich
nie. Gewicht alleine reicht mir. Was kaufe? Wie gesagt, alles mögliche. Von Zeug für die Katze,
von ein bisschen Technik Kram, Sachen fürs Fahrrad zum Rasieren, T-Shirts, alle möglichen
Dinger. Muss mal gucken. Ich habe nämlich schon ein paar Sachen zusammen geklickt. Bei mir jetzt
Offscreen, Offstream. Habe ich mir gedacht, wir machen das jetzt mal zusammen. Wir haben schon
lange keinen, ich kaufe mir sinnlose, wobei sinnlos sind die Sachen ja nicht. Ich kaufe mir
Dinge ein. Die Körperfettanalyse in den Waagen ist auch Scam. Wenn du das sagst, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich könnte mir halt vorstellen, dass es schwierig ist, das nur von einem Fuß zum anderen zu messen.
Keck Bros. Gewicht wird Chat auch beschenkt. Vielleicht, wenn der Chat brav ist, gibt es
vielleicht einen Prime Sub. Ich habe mich gemessen. Ich hatte gestern, ich weiß es gar
nicht mehr. Ich habe es euch doch vorhin erzählt. Ich glaube 91,2 oder so. 91,1, 91,2. Und wahrscheinlich
hätte ich, und das war bevor ich Rennen war. Nach dem Rennen hätte ich definitiv unter 91 gehabt.
Hätte ich wahrscheinlich 91,7 oder so gehabt. Aber das ist natürlich beschiss,
weil da schwitzt man ja zum größten Teil Zeug raus. Und das bringt es ja auch nicht.
Massive. Danke für den Sub. So ist das. Man muss einfach nur fragen,
ob man was geschenkt kriegt im Chat. Und schon kriegt man was. Nice. So mag ich,
so mag ich das Chat. Massive. Way too high IQ. Aber gab auf jeden Fall wieder IQ Boost für alle.
Ja, also ich bin zuversichtlich, wenn ich das mit Fahrradfahren und Rennen weitermache. Ich
muss, ich brauche noch einen gescheiten Rhythmus. Ja, also aktuell mache ich es ja so. Ein Tag Rennen,
ein Tag Pause, ein Tag Rennen, ein Tag Pause. Wenn ich, wenn ich ganz hart drauf bin, mache
ich vielleicht Samstag Rennen und Sonntag morgens ein bisschen länger und dafür super langsam. Aber
eigentlich ist es ein Tag Rennen, ein Tag Pause, ein Tag Rennen, ein Tag Pause. Ich muss gucken,
wo ich das, wo ich das Fahrradfahren unterbringe. Ob ich das Fahrradfahren nachmittags unterbringe,
an den Tagen, wo ich gerennt habe oder an den Tagen dazwischen. Aber ab und zu mal einen Tag
ganz komplett Pause, damit man sich komplett erholen kann, ist auch nicht verkehrt. Ja,
vielleicht mache ich auch einen Tag Rennen, einen Tag Pause, einen Tag Fahrradfahren,
einen Tag Rennen, einen Tag Pause. Ich weiß es noch nicht. Oder, oder einen Tag Rennen, Pause,
Fahrradfahren, Rennen, Pause. Sowas, sowas vielleicht. Heute Fahrradzubehör. Auch,
auch. Heute kommen wir auf Fahrradzubehör. Ich brauche noch Handschuhe, beziehungsweise ich
habe bei Amazon heute Morgen ja schon geguckt. Ich habe die noch nicht bestellt. Welche zweite
Fremdsprache hattet ihr denn im Abi? Kobol. Ah, ok. Ich hatte keine. Heute geradelt oder gelaufen?
Nichts. Gar nichts heute gemacht. Ich war am, ich war am Freitag Rennen und Fahrradfahren und ich
war gestern nur Fahrradfahren und heute habe ich mir gedacht, ich mache heute einfach mal nix.
Mein Arsch tut mir weh und meine Oberschenkel. Da habe ich mir gedacht, ey, mal einen Tag
ausruhen, das muss auch mal normal sein. Ja, Massive Hyper Gachi. Hast du in einer Zeit Abi
gemacht, wo man schon alles außer Sport abwählen konnte? Nicht, dass das hier jemand gemacht hat,
aber das ist eine andere Sache. Nee, bei mir war das noch anders. Nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass ich überhaupt kein Abi gemacht habe. Was das? Ich bin Low IQ Bildungs Noob. Ich habe kein Abi.
Ich habe weder was studiert, weder an der FH noch an der Uni, noch habe ich, ich habe noch nicht mal
ein Abitur. Ich habe gar nix. Ich, das, das war eine Zeit, da habe ich 24-7 MMO Kreisel Grind
gemacht. Also danach dann. Danach, als ich hätte zumindest Fachabi machen können, hatte ich keinen
Bock. Da habe ich 24-7 MMO Kreisel Grind gemacht und dann wurde ich dazu gezwungen, eine BWL-Ausbildung
zu machen, die ich abgebrochen habe. Und irgendwann, ich wollte ja damals schon, weiß nicht, ob es
damals schon Physi gab, aber sowas in der Richtung machen. Und das habe ich dann erst Jahre später
gemacht. Aber seitdem ging es bergauf. Da habe ich endlich das gefunden, was ich machen will.
Aber du kannst natürlich, wir können ja die Frage an den Chat weitergeben. Vielleicht kann sich da
einer was dazu äußern. Ich kann dazu dann gar nichts sagen. Was hältst du von ein Tag Pause,
ein Tag Pause, ein Tag Pause erstmal? Ja, das ist auch nice. Das ist ja im Prinzip Dauerpause.
Und am besten ein Tag Pause und ein Tag dann ordentlich Pipo Fett reinfressen. Und nächsten
Tag Pause und dann wieder reinfressen. Das ist dann exzellent. Road to 200 Kilo. Challenge.
Bei diesen Wahlen nächste Woche. Nicht heute, nächste Woche am 8. Wir machen irgendwann im
Laufe der nächsten Woche, spätestens Sonntagmorgen, machen wir mal wieder den Wahl-O-Mat. Da bin ich
aber heute zu braindead für. Was hat denn T-Online damit zu tun? Okay, die schreiben einfach nur
drüber. Also bei mir ist es so, ich habe prinzipiell immer drei Tage frei die Woche.
Weil ich habe Samstag frei, Sonntag frei und Montag ist immer frei. Dafür bekomme ich aber
auch weniger Geld. Also das hält sich natürlich in Grenzen. Muss man sich überlegen, was einem
mehr wert ist. Mir ist die Freizeit auf jeden Fall mehr wert. Anstatt mehr Geld. Weil die Kohle
geht auch so voll klar. So, ich muss noch kurz andere Musik reinmachen. Oh ja, wupp wupp wupp,
Epik. Epik wupp wupp wupp, wupp wupp wupp, wupp wupp wupp wupp, wupp wupp wupp wupp. Also ich bin ja
öfters mal in Bayern, weil die bayerische Grenze nicht weit weg ist. Und ich glaube, ich habe noch
keine anderen Wahlplakate dort gesehen als CSU. Doch, doch, doch, ich habe die Bayern-Partei,
ist mir noch aufgefallen, oder wie die heißen. Da stand irgendwie sowas wie drauf, wie es reicht,
jetzt kommen wir, oder irgendwie sowas. Die Bayern-Partei. Aber ansonsten habe ich in Bayern
eigentlich nur CSU-Plakate gesehen. Ich bin ja öfters mal über der bayerischen Grenze. Ist ja
nicht weit von mir. Ich wohne in Hanau, ein bisschen neben Hanau. Und ein paar Kilometer,
so 15 Kilometer oder so, ist die bayerische Grenze. Ich kriege da öfters auch mal mit,
was in Bayern so abgeht. Ich werde schon mal Amazon aufmachen. Wir starten mal ein neues
Browser-Fenster, weil das ist eins, was ich hier nachher zumachen muss. Zu viele. Okay,
Leute, ich interessiere mich nicht für die Serie. Ich will aber mal was checken. Und zwar
ob Amazon immer noch bei neuen Serien... Oh shit, Alter! Wait a minute! Das hat 33 negativ
und 47 5 Sterne. Aber hier hat es 5 Sterne. Moment, Amazon! Wait a minute! Da ist irgendwas
nicht so ganz richtig, würde ich sagen. Schalt mal deinen Darkreader aus. Was liegt daran? Ah!
Darkreader! Debated! Okay, das trifft schon eher. Was ich aber eigentlich gucken wollte,
ist, ob Amazon... Ja, machen sie. Das ist der neueste Trend bei Amazon, dass einfach alle
Rezensionen für neue Serien ausgeblendet werden, nachdem Amazon-Produktionen manchmal in den
letzten Jahren übelst beschissen bewertet wurden. Wahrscheinlich so zurecht. Ich habe das nicht
geguckt, aber wahrscheinlich zurecht. Darmstall ist auch nicht so weit weg. Ein bisschen,
aber nicht so ultra weit. Okay, das war wirklich der Darkreader. Twitch und YouTube machen die
Regel. Du kannst davon ausgehen, dass bei mir weder YouTube noch Twitch-Money aktuell irgendwas
regelt. Das ist nice, dass man ein bisschen ab und zu zusätzlich noch was verdient. Es ist aber
nicht so, als würde ich fett damit Kohle machen. Dafür mache ich doch auch im Prinzip viel zu
wenig. Ich lade aktuell 1-2 Mal, wenn es hochkommt, im Monat ein Video auf YouTube hoch und streame
in letzter Zeit sogar relativ unregelmäßig auf Twitch. Ich meine, ist es schön, dass immer so
viele dabei sind. Das freut mich auch. Vor allem, weil mein Chat auch sehr angenehm ist. Aber ich
hatte durchaus schon höhere Subscriber-Counts als jetzt. Man hat es gesehen, so mal als ich
zwei Monate am Stück volle Pulle live gestreamt habe. Ist auch gar nicht lang her. Ich habe ja
bis vor ungefähr eineinhalb Monaten oder so wirklich sehr viel gestreamt. Da habe ich aber
auch nicht so viel Sport gemacht, weil irgendwie ist das schwierig, das alles zu vereinbaren.
Da hatte ich 9 Rekord-Subscriber-Counts. Streamst du weniger wegen der Arbeit? Ja,
naja. Wegen der Arbeit ist es aktuell tatsächlich vielleicht ein bisschen weniger. Vor allem habe
ich ein bisschen weniger Bock auf Technik-Kram abends. Es gibt zumindest auch gerade nichts,
wo ich groß darauf Bock habe. Aber seitdem ich angefangen habe, regelmäßig zu rennen und jetzt
auch noch Fahrrad fahren irgendwann, muss man das ja auch machen. Und wenn ich dann voll im Arsch
bin, abends noch drei Stunden streamen, weiß nicht. Warum haben wir eigentlich ein Lick-Command?
Irgendwie ist das ziemlich weirdchamp. IRL-Stream. Ja, da sind wir doch eigentlich schon gerade beim
Thema. Ich brauche eine Sonnenbrille, beziehungsweise eine Brille fürs Fahrrad. Ja,
schon lange, aber die Frage ist, warum? Ja, es gibt ein Fahrrad-Kommando. War das nicht
Ausrufezeichen Fahrrad? Oder war es nur Ausrufezeichen Rad? Ah, hä? Wenn Mothris das machen
geht's? Ach, weil es Reply war. Genau. Das ist mein Bike. Leider kein Bild in der Vorschau. So
sieht's aus hier. Guck. So hier. Pogu-Bike. Massive nice. Aber ich hab das erst seit letzter
Woche Dienstag. Also, nee, heute ist ja noch Sonntag. Seit dieser Woche Dienstag. Seit hier
irgendwann. Und ich bin erst zweimal gefahren. Ich bin hier und hier gefahren jetzt erst. Ja,
wenn schon, dann richtig. Eigentlich unsinnig teuer für einen Noob wie mich. Aber für jeden was
muss ich meine Kohle noch ausgeben. So Leute, ich mache mal kurz meine VM an. Einmal kurz
Package-Updates bei Arch, by the way, installieren. Fällt mir gerade so ein,
dass man wieder Zeit wird. So. Rolling Release Arch, by the way. Was? Car-Gui-Addons. Was ist
das überhaupt? Was bin ich hier sehend? Addons für Gui. Okay, ja, installier mal. Perfekt.
Macht mal. Arch Linux Five Heads. So, hier einmal schnell alles installieren. Was ist
EDK 2? EDK 2. Habt ihr das gesehen? Wir lieben Lebensmittel. EDK 2 ist. Ah. UEFI-Zeug. Oh,
neuer Kernel. Ob der Bug gefixt ist, dass meine VM laggt? Das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Ich starte jetzt mal neu. Ja, das darf auch mal installiert werden. Ich starte jetzt mal
neu und gucken, ob die VM noch laggt. Ohne, also mit dem LTS-Kernel hat sie ja nie gelaggt. Aber
ich werde mal neu starten und gucken. Das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren. Was will meine Leiste
da oben von mir? Ah, okay, easy. Hat sich von selbst gefixt. Benutze irgendwelche Tools zum
Dokumente zu verwalten, z.B. Evernote oder sowas. Ja, mache ich. Ich benutze das hier. Weil hier im
Stream habe ich natürlich nichts drinne stehen. Das benutze ich. Ganz ehrlich, das ist sicherlich
nicht die aller allerbeste Notizverwaltung, die es gibt. Aber da gibt es rein in der Disziplin
vom puren Editieren. Das ist bestimmt bessere. Aber das Gute ist, die gibt es für alle gängigen
Betriebssysteme, inklusive iOS und Android. Und die haben Notification Support. Die hat
Notification Support auf allen Plattformen und das ist extrem nice. Das macht alles. Das synct,
updatet alle und inklusive our-packages. Ich glaube, das Y ist sogar doppelt gemoppelt.
Das braucht man gar nicht doppelt. Was hast du dir von Pedalen geholt? Sowas, was die beim
Checkout empfohlen haben, aber so wirklich zufrieden bin ich nicht. Das sind so Hybridpedale
auf der einen Seite flach, auf der anderen Seite zum reinklicken. Aber nachdem ich nicht reinklicke
und auch mich erstmal nicht traue mit den Schuhen zu fahren, mache ich wahrscheinlich noch andere
dran, die auf beiden Seiten flach sind. So, jetzt hoffe ich mal, dass es nicht mal laggt in meiner
4M, wenn ich das normale Linux starte. Werden wir gleich sehen. Das dauert zu lang. Ich sehe
schon. Ich sehe gleich, das ist laggy. Guck mal. Guck mal, wie lange das hängt. Seht ihr das? Das
ist laggy. Ich merke es direkt. Der lag ist real, Leute. Nee, reicht. Achso, Moment. Es stimmt ja
auch nicht, was ich gesagt habe. Nicht our-packages. Our-Git-Packages werden mit
Devil auch noch mit installiert. So, laggt es noch? Ja, seht ihr? Es laggt. Habt ihr es gesehen?
Habt ihr? Ihr seht das? Ihr seht das? Es laggt. Ja, ja, ja. Okay, anscheinend hat der neue Kernel
das Problem nicht gefixt. Da muss ich nochmal rebooten und zurück zum LTS-Kernel. Gut, dass
es den LTS-Kernel gibt. Ich habe den bisher seltenst gebraucht unter Arch-Linux, aber wenn
man ihn braucht, dann ist gut, dass es ihn gibt. Seht ihr, wie schnell das bootet? Viel schneller
und ganz ohne Probleme. So, aber kommen wir mal zurück zum Geld ausgeben. Bester Background.
Why does pepo happy? So, zur Entspannung. Eine Runde Fische. Nee, nee, ich glaube, da brauchst du
minus minus Devil, dass das Git-Packages mitmacht. Gibt es kein Kommando für. Kannst aber auf Git
gehen und dir meine Konfig-Files angucken. Moin Nudelwasser. Da kannst du dir meine Konfigs angucken
und die 3 gibt es hier. Prompt für die Shell gibt es da. Terminal-Konfig gibt es da. Korrekt. Gut,
also machen wir Amazon auf, beziehungsweise ein paar andere Shops. Also lass mal überlegen,
was ist das Erste, was ich brauche? Katze, was ist los? Katze macht da an der Tür irgendwelche
Action gerade. Moment, Moment, Darkreader muss eingeschaltet werden. Chico, Chico,
was machst du da? Dann nicht. Chico mag das nicht, wenn die Tür zu ist. Wo wir gerade dabei sind,
dann fangen wir doch mal an, was für Chico zu kaufen. Ich brauche nämlich für Chico,
ich brauche für Chico mehrere Sachen. Nachdem ich Chico für den Tierarzt eine Urinprobe schicken
muss, brauche ich folgendes. Es gibt, also das kenne ich von meiner letzten Katze, es gibt
Katzenstreu. Das sind so Perlen. Ich weiß, ich glaube, das ist das. Ich glaube, das ist das. Ja,
genau und zwar, das ist natürlich das schlechteste Bild ever. Das ist Katzenstreu, was nicht aufsaugt.
Das ist Katzenstreu, was sich für die Katze anfühlt wie Katzenstreu, aber es saugt es nicht
auf. Also sprich, man kann das reinmachen in das Katzenklo. Die Katze denkt, oh nice,
kein Katzenstreu. Geht rein, pinkeln und danach kann man Urinprobe aus dem Klo holen. Ja, manche
finden das jetzt eklig, aber als Katzenbesitzer muss man das ab und zu mal machen. Das brauche
ich auf jeden Fall. Und ein Package, wie viele gibt es denn da? Gibt es da vielleicht auch ein
Dreierpack oder sowas? Zweimal. Ich hätte auf jeden Fall gerne ein bisschen mehr, weil die Katze
geht da nicht rein, wenn da so wenig drin ist. Ganz ehrlich, die Bilder sind einfach kacke. Mal
gucken, ob es da irgendwelche... Ja, hier erkennt man es besser. Guck, das sind so kleine Perlen,
wo das dann durchläuft. Also es sind zwei. Da brauche ich auf jeden Fall zweimal zwei,
dass ich das Klo ordentlich ein bisschen was reinkriege, sonst geht die Katze da nicht drauf.
Zack, haben wir schon das Erste. So, Erste für Chico. Das brauche ich. Nächste für Chico,
was ich brauche ist, ich habe es mir irgendwo aufgeschrieben, aber da haken wir nämlich mal
ganz schnell die Katzengeschichten ab. Wo ist es denn? Das brauche ich noch für Chico, weil Chico
hat... Chico ist alt und alte Katzen haben ja ganz gerne mal ein bisschen Nierenprobleme. Das
ist ein Proteinzusatzergänzungsfutter für... Warte mal, ist das das Proteinzeug oder sind
das die Kügelchen? Ich bin gerade verwirrt. Ne, das sind die Ergänzungsdinger. Ja, da brauche ich
auch eine Kiste. Ich weiß nicht, was ein guter Preis ist. Muss mal vergleichen mit dem, was es
beim Tierarzt gibt, aber ich packe es mal zweimal 30. Einmal 30, dann ist das sogar ein bisschen...
Alter, ist das teuer, man! Aber gut, was war mal nicht für die Katze? Zack. Ja, alte Katze...
Alte Katze ist teuer. Moment, warum habe ich nicht eben ein extra Browserfenster aufgemacht,
nur für Amazon? Ja, doch. Alte Katze zu haben ist teuer, aber das macht nichts. Chico kriegt
alles, was sie braucht. Ja, ist schon teuer. So, dann haben wir mal das Zeug für die Katze
abgehakt. Als nächstes, übrigens als Fahrradcomputer, ich muss mal gucken, ob es die
mittlerweile bei Amazon gibt. Ich habe mir den direkt von Garmin bestellt. Von Garmin habe ich mir
einen Garmin Edge 840 gekauft, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen, und ich verstehe nicht, warum, gibt es
bei Amazon nur die letzte Konsolengeneration, sozusagen. Die haben keine... Die haben nur 530 und
8... Ach, guck mal! Jetzt gibt es den, aber US... Ach, deswegen ist es auch so teuer. US-Import. Ja, das lohnt sich nicht.
Ja, so ein Teil, wo wir gerade dabei sind, so ein Teil will ich mir auch kaufen. Das gibt es. Also,
das ist wirklich nice. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es so toll ist, wie sich das anhört, ja, aber von
der Idee her ist das mega nice. Und zwar, das ist ein Rücklicht fürs Fahrrad. Das ist ein Rücklicht
fürs Fahrrad mit Radar. Und wenn sich von hinten was nähert... Ich weiß nicht, ob die ein gescheites Bild dabei
haben. Ja, so sieht es auf dem Smartphone aus, ist aber dumm. Das kannst du mit deinem Fahrradcomputer
koppeln. Und das zeigt dir dann an, wenn beispielsweise ein Auto von hinten kommt,
oder irgendwie irgendwas anderes von hinten kommt, dann macht es ein Geräusch. Und ich bin mir gar
nicht... Ganz ehrlich, ich habe gar keine Ahnung, wie das aussieht. Wie die Anzeige auf einem Edge
überhaupt aussieht. Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht gibt es da irgendwie ein Bild für. Da war es doch hier.
Ja, ach, guck mal. Man sieht dann irgendwie auf dem Edge... Okay, das ist ganz interessant. Man sieht
dann auf dem Edge irgendwie an den Seiten, von wo was kommt oder so. Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Ja, also sowas will ich mir bestellen. Ja, ich weiß, Chat, das gibt es auch noch mit Kamera,
aber ich werde es mir nicht kaufen mit Kamera, weil... Hier, guck. Weil das irgendwie von dem
Licht ein bisschen unpraktischer aussieht und weil das auch mehr Akku... Also erstens kostet es doppelt
so viel und der Akkuverbrauch ist auch noch höher. Also ich finde, außerdem braucht man da gar keine
Kamera. Ich weiß nicht, also irgendwie... Ich werde mir höchstwahrscheinlich das Normale kaufen.
Ah, Dashcam. Da pappe ich mir lieber eine GoPro vorne drauf und habe ich ein bisschen Hintergrund
Videomaterial. Bin ich gar nicht und auch nicht lang. Ich habe das Fahrrad erster Dienstag. Ich
muss mich jetzt erst mal ausstatten mit basic Zeug. Das Kamerabild kann man sich nicht anzeigen lassen
während der Fahrt. Das wäre natürlich cool, könnte man ein Kamerabild auf dem Garmin anzeigen,
aber das geht nicht. Du bekommst, du bekommst nur das Radar. Die Radarwarnung da drauf. Was
mit Montagepaste? Liqui Moly. Wozu genau brauche ich das? Ich brauche keine Montagepaste. Ist das
für Carbon oder? Nee, keine Ahnung. Hast du das Rad von Rose als Produktplacement bekommen? Nein.
Hätte ich nichts dagegen gehabt. Also Rose, falls ihr noch irgendwie was sponsern wollt. Ich bin
offen für alles. Ich werde demnächst eh neuer Fifed Strafe-Influencer. Also wenn ihr wollt,
stream Twitch, YouTube. YouTube fast 300k Subscriptions pro Video. So irgendwie was
zwischen 25 und 65k, kann man immer auf YouTube schlecht sagen, Aufrufe. Und auf Twitch so irgendwas
um 150, 250 Zuschauer. Wir machen zwar normalerweise überhaupt nichts mit Fahrrädern
und Sport, aber vielleicht ist das ja genau eure Chance, Rose. Da könnt ihr auch irgendwelchen
IT-Kellerkindern eure Fahrräder näher bringen. Was habt ihr davon, wenn ihr das überall präsentiert?
Leute, die eh schon ganz viel Sport machen, eh schon Fahrräder haben. Hier habt ihr 90 Prozent
der Leute, 95 Prozent der Leute, die wahrscheinlich viel zu dick sind, überhaupt Fahrrad zu fahren.
Das heißt, da könnt ihr noch richtig was abgreifen. Also Rose, wenn ihr wollt, E-Mail steht in der
Beschreibung. Naja, ich bin auch eigentlich ein bisschen zu dick dafür. Das Fahrrad ist zugelassen
für 100 bis zu 110 Kilo. Ich, vor einem Jahr hätte ich das noch nicht, also vor zwei Jahren hätte ich
das noch nicht fahren können. Also vor zwei Jahren hätte ich das noch nicht fahren können. Da hätte
ich 108,5 Kilo gehabt und mit ein bisschen Zeug dran wäre ich locker über 110 gekommen. Mit Fahrrad,
ja, ja, ja, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, mit Fahrrad, deswegen ja, sag ich ja, ich weiß. Das ist inklusive
Fahrrad. Und jetzt, und jetzt habe ich halt, sagen wir mal so 92 mit Fahrrad, sagen wir mal 9 Kilo,
jetzt habe ich halt 100, so 100 ungefähr mit Fahrrad. Oder 101, 102 mit so zwischen 100 und
101 und 102 mit Fahrrad. Also ich bin drunter, gut drunter unter 110, aber ein paar Kilo weniger
wäre natürlich auch für berghoch nicht schlecht. Also ich hätte vor zwei Jahren das noch nicht
mal fahren können. Aber die haben auch Fahrräder, die für ein bisschen schwerere sind. Gibt sogar
eine Tabelle bei denen. Also Rose, wenn ihr, wenn ihr hier komplett neuen Markt euch erschließen
wollt, dann, ich bin immer offen für alles. Also so ein Teil will ich mir auf jeden Fall holen in
den Einkaufswagen. Nein, nein, nein, Amazon geht mir nicht mit dem Scheiß auf den Sack. Einfach
hinzufügen, zack bumm. Ja, vorderlich bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher. Also aktuell habe ich an meinem
Fahrrad, man muss ja, man muss ja gucken, weil so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen zumindest guten
Willen zeigen, dass man verkehrstüchtiges Fahrrad hat, muss man ja auch. Also ich habe an meinem
Fahrrad, ich habe einen kleinen Helm, einen Helm habe ich auch, einen Helm habe ich, einen Helm habe ich. Also ich
habe, also an meinem Fahrrad habe ich einmal dran einen Rückreflektor und zwar so einen ganz, so was, ja
genau den. So einen ganz billigen Furz kleinen, aber der ist zertifiziert und zugelassen. Der stört auch
kaum. So, so ein Teil habe ich dran und wir können es ja mal rein machen, so als hätten wir es heute
gekauft. So ein Teil habe ich dran und ich habe, ja aber nicht die, Speichenreflektoren. So was, so
in der Richtung. So was hier, ich, keine Ahnung, ob es exakt das ist. So was hier habe ich an den
Rädern dran. Theoretisch muss man sagen, gibt es, also ich habe mich da ein bisschen schlau gemacht,
gibt es drei Sachen, die wohl okay sind, gesetzlich, gesetzesmäßig und zwar das erste ist so die
klassischen Reflektoren, diese Katzenaugen dran zu machen. Dann sind Speichersticks, so was wie hier
auch erlaubt, aber da muss an jeder Speiche ein Stick sein, sonst ist es nicht erlaubt. Letztendlich
kontrolliert wird es wahrscheinlich eh nie, ja. Aber nur mal so, was, das ist ja mein Unterschied zwischen dem, was
man machen muss und was da wirklich kontrolliert wird oder, was auch okay ist, wenn man sich Reifen
kauft mit so einem Reflektorring drauf. Wohlgemerkt, den Reflektorring darf man nachträglich nicht
anbringen, das gilt nur für Reifen, die mit Zertifizierung und Reflektorring verkauft wurden.
Also so ein Teil, so ein Teil habe ich, habe ich auch dran, so und das, das reicht eigentlich. Frontreflektor
fehlt eigentlich noch, okay. Samuel, danke für den Sub. Habe ich irgendwas vergessen? Vorher Leute, nein. Wenn man nie in der
Nacht fährt, muss man die Sachen wirklich haben, die, ja musst du. Also zumindest, also oft, also du musst
mindestens einen Vorder-, einen Rück-, einen Vorder-, einen Frontreflektor, einen Rückreflektor und
Speichenreflektoren haben. Lichter musst du nicht haben, aber und du brauchst, du brauchst Pedale mit
Reflektoren, korrekt, korrekt. Lichter musst du nicht haben, Lichter musst du aber haben, wenn es die
Sichtbedingungen erfordern. Ja, selbst denen fehlen Rücklichter und sowas teilweise. Ich habe, ich habe
bei Rose geguckt, die hatten auch Dinger, wo man sich denkt, ja da fehlt ja die Hälfte. Naja, aber
es ist immer so ein Ding, kontrolliert wird man wahrscheinlich auf den, das ist eh nicht. Also ich
habe auch keinen richtigen Frontreflektor dran. Ich habe auch nur so ein Band, so ein Band dran. Gut,
also, ja, ach so, ja und als Klingel, als Klingel habe ich sowas ganz kleines, billiges und zwar
heißt das so, das ist im Prinzip ein Stück Metall mit einem Kabelbinder dran, sowas hier. Ich glaube,
ich habe nicht V6, also keine Ahnung, meins hat irgendwie 899 oder so gekostet. Keine AirTag-Klingel,
nee. Sowas habe ich, ich habe es ganz normal am Lenker dran. Das ist mega billig, das Ding, aber
es erfüllt seinen Zweck. Airhorn, das ist nicht erlaubt, du brauchst eine mechanische Klingel.
Das ist ein ganz kleines Furzding, fällt überhaupt nicht auf, lässt sich easy installieren mit dem,
mit dem Kabelbinder und macht halt Bim, wenn man dran zieht. Fertig, mehr braucht man nicht. Klingel,
so. So ein Teil habe ich auch noch am Fahrrad. Aber das wollte ich heute eigentlich gar nicht,
also ich zeige euch das jetzt einfach, das muss ich nicht kaufen, das habe ich schon. Das brauche
ich nicht. Ach, es gibt mal wieder Prime Day. Wann ist denn das? 10. bis 11. Oktober. Okay,
mal wieder zwei Tage, wo es ganz ganz viel Scheiß gibt, den keiner braucht. Aber vielleicht das
ein oder andere. Also Prime Day ist immer gut, wenn man Amazon eigene Sachen kaufen will,
zum Beispiel ein Fire HD Tablet oder sowas. Wobei ich die Tablets auch nur empfehlen kann,
die ploatet oder noch besser mit Custom-Firmware, falls es aktuell Exploits gibt, zum Routen und
Firmware installieren. Und ansonsten ist, sind die Prime Days meistens, ja für SSD Storage und
Storage, also es ist vereinzelt schon ganz gutes Zeug dabei, aber größtenteils ist es eigentlich
ganz viel, ganz viel Müll, was niemand braucht. Richtig, Luftpumpe brauche ich, das ist richtig,
Luftpumpe habe ich noch keine. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es sich lohnt, eine Luftpumpe mitzunehmen.
Da bin ich echt noch ein bisschen unschlüssig, weil ich habe noch keinen, so erste, nennen wir es
mal Erste-Hilfe-Kit. Also ich meine damit jetzt nicht, um mich zu verarzten, sondern ich habe
keinen, falls irgendwas mal was ist mit dem Fahrrad. Ja, genau, so eine Satteltasche oder irgendwas in
der Richtung brauche ich auch. Das Ding ist halt, ich weiß nicht, ob es sich lohnt, eine Luftpumpe
mitzunehmen, weil wir haben tatsächlich auch, wir haben tatsächlich auch Repair-Stations teilweise
auf dem Weg. Habe ich schon. Ich habe aber Tubeless-Reifen, da ist ja so eine Milch,
so eine, wie nennt man das? Hat jemand eine Ahnung von euch, wie man das richtig nennt?
Da ist so eine Dichtmasse, Dichtmilch, Dichtmilch, genau, ist da drin und wenn man mal kleine Löcher
hat, dann verschließen die sich automatisch. Warnweste? Nee, brauche ich nicht. Ich habe
meistens ein weißes, ein weißes, wie nennt man sowas, so Funktionst-T-Shirt an, das ist hell
genug und mein Fahrrad hat auch genug Reflektoren. Ich brauche keine, ich hätte theoretisch eine
Warnweste, aber ich brauche keine Warnweste. Hat dein Rad französisches oder Auto französisches?
Französisches Ventil. Was, es gibt eine Luftpumpe? Wirklich? Die haben eine Luftpumpe? What? Das ist
eine Luftpumpe mit einem Schloss? Das ist, das ist Unsinn. Das will ich doch nicht mitnehmen,
so ein klobiges Ding. Und das Schloss ist fürs Fahrrad, sagen wir mal auch, nicht wirklich zu
gebrauchen, weil wie willst du dort, wie willst du mit dem Schloss gescheit deinen Rahmen anschließen?
Du kannst das Schloss ums Fahrrad klipsen, ja geil. Mein Fahrrad wiegt 8,5 Kilo, das nimmt
jemand unter den Arm und ist weg, wenn ich es vor der Bäckerei abstelle. Aber Moment, das ist
kein Schloss. Ah, ich dachte es ist ein Schloss mit integrierter Luftpumpe. Das ist eine Luftpumpe,
die aussieht wie ein Schloss. Nee, das ist blöd. Da ist auch ein Akku drinnen und so, das ist
wahrscheinlich viel zu schwer. Ich will, wenn überhaupt irgendwas Kleines, Handliches. Aber ich
glaube, ich brauche gerade keine Luftpumpe. Eine Sonnenbrille brauche ich, tatsächlich. Das ist
auch noch ein Ding, brauche ich heute. Chatgy, was empfiehlt ihr mir für eine Sonnenbrille? Also
ich habe mir im Vorfeld schon mal was angeguckt. Du hast die hier. Okay, lass mal kurz checken.
Profit, keep moving. Profit. Ey, war Profit nicht der Typ aus Crysis? Fußpumpe, Rahmenpumpe,
Akkupumpe, Standpumpe. Was eine Sonnen... Moment, was, was, was? Eine Sonnenbrille mit Bone
Conduction, um unterwegs Sachen zu hören. What? Ach, du meinst mit Sachen hören? Ach,
jetzt verstehe ich es. Sound abspielen, dass du dabei Podcast hören kannst oder sowas.
Nee. Ich muss sagen, ich bin auch beim Rennen kein großer Fan von Musik oder irgendwelchen
Sachen dabei. Ich renne am liebsten und kriege was von meiner Umwelt mit. Das liegt bei mir aber
auch daran, weil ich halt sonst so viel vorm Computer sitze mit Headset auf, Musik laufen
oder hier im Stream. Ich finde es echt mal entspannend, beim Rennen einfach nur nichts
oder die Sounds um mich drum herum mitzubekommen. Wow, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel des
Guten, oder? Also was ich mir, was ich mir überlegt habe ist, es gibt, wie heißt das Ding, sowas. Das
fand ich prinzipiell von der Idee her ganz cool. Erstens ist die im Vergleich zu manchen anderen
relativ günstig. Und was ich bei der ganz cool finde, ist, die passt sich automatisch den
Helligkeitsbedingungen an. Ich habe halt keine Ahnung, wie gut das funktioniert. Also jetzt ist
die klar und wenn Sonne scheint, dann wird die dunkel. Weiß ich, ob es da vielleicht, gibt es
da vielleicht ein Testvideo zu? Varioautomatik, ja hier. Das ist ein Werbevideo von denen. Ja,
guckt, wenn, je nach, je nach Wetter, ändert sich. Ich finde die Idee eigentlich ganz nice.
Die kann man auch zum Laufen mitnehmen, bestimmt, bestimmt, ja. Das ist doof, wenn du unter einer
Brücke durch musst. Okay, da unter einer Brücke kann ich mir das vorstellen, weil so schnell ändert
sich das nicht. Aber andere Sonnenbrillen sind halt auch immer dunkel. Die hat halt wenigstens
den, die Chance, dann wieder hell zu werden. Wenn du dir irgendeine Sonnenbrille kaufst, dann ist
die halt, die sich nicht anpasst, da hast du das gleiche Problem. Also ich, also ich denke mal, ich
werde erst sowas probieren. Es gibt ja ganz abgedrehte Sachen. Hat ja auch schon hier einer
Oakley geschrieben. Aber von denen gibt es genau mit Prism und, und wie heißt der, was es nicht noch
alles gibt. Das Problem ist halt, was heißt Problem? Ich sehe es zumindest noch nicht ein.
Das Ding ist halt, dass hier dann teilweise das Dreifache für ausgeben kannst und das ist noch
nicht mal exakt die, die ich dann haben will. Also ich, ich bin mir da nicht sicher. Ich glaube,
ich werde es erst mal mit etwas günstigeren probieren und mal schauen, wie das so ist.
Ich meine, mehr Geld ausgeben kann man immer. Wenn du noch Pedale brauchst, okay, zeig mal,
ja. Look. Es ist nicht einfach nur eine Plastikbrille, es ist eine Plastikbrille,
wo sich der Sonnenbrillengrad, das der jeweiligen Außenbeleuchtung anpasst. Also wenn viel Sonne
scheint, wird die dunkler und ansonsten wird die heller. Und das finde ich von Features her,
ehrlich gesagt, ganz nice. Also quasi nice, nice. Wir haben noch keinen Valor Mart gemacht.
Wahrscheinlich mache ich den irgendwann die Woche oder eben spätestens nächsten Sonntag.
Ja, okay, okay, Chat Gil. Also wer hat das jetzt hier empfohlen? Sesam Seed. Also warum
würdest du mir diese Pedale empfehlen? Weil bringen sie ihre Persönlichkeit zum Ausdruck.
Okay, welches Marketinghirn hat sich das ausgedacht? Inwieweit bringe ich mit diesem
Pedal meine Persönlichkeit zum Ausdruck? Also Chat, was für, wenn ich, mal genommen,
ich hätte dieses Pedal und ihr seht jetzt dieses Pedal, was für eine Persönlichkeit habe ich dann?
Zu viel Geld. Keine Ahnung. 67 Euro. Für eins? Nee, wahrscheinlich für zwei. Also wenn ich mir neue
Pedale hole, dann tatsächlich welche, die minimal mehr Abstand hier haben. Weil bei mir ist es ja so,
ich fahre ja aktuell noch ohne irgendwelche Klick-Schuhe und sonst was. Und ich habe aber
extra breite Schuhe. Und ich habe das Problem, wenn ich wirklich komplett meinen Fuß ran stelle
am Pedal, dann trete ich manchmal hinten leicht auf die Kurbel, wenn ich den Fuß nicht exakt so
ein bisschen nach außen mache. Also insofern hätte ich, wäre so ein Pedal, was irgendwie
so einen halben Zentimeter, ups, was so einen halben Zentimeter weg wäre von so der Kurbel,
wahrscheinlich ganz praktisch. Allzu weit weg sollte es natürlich auch nicht sein,
weil sonst bleibst du in Kurven noch irgendwie an der Erde hängen oder so. Ja, mache ich. Ich
weiß nicht, ob das am Fahrrad liegt. Ich meine, es ist halt zu klein. Es könnte auch an meinen
komischen Pedalen liegen, die ich damit möglich. Also ich trete, ich trete ja nicht irgendwie auf
die Kette, ich trete so neben ein bisschen auf das Metall vom Pedal. Das kann man relativ einfach
fixen, indem man den Fuß absichtlich ein bisschen weiter außen platziert. Da geht das, ist kein
Problem. Aber es ist trotzdem nervig, dass man immer darauf achten muss. Das heißt, so ein Pedal,
was vielleicht so einen halben Zentimeter Offset hat, wäre schon cool. So, aber gehen wir mal auf
Amazon. Das wüsste ich jetzt nicht. Boah, keine Ahnung. Ich warte erst mal ab, bis Winter ist,
ob ich da noch Bock drauf habe. Ich meine, ab und zu wäre das natürlich nicht schlecht. Dann
gewöhnt sich der Arsch wenigstens weiterhin dran. Moment, wenn ich Pedale hole, die etwas
breiter sind, ändert das nicht meine Anatomie, sondern das Fahrrad ist doch genau das, was du
schreibst. Die Pedale gehören ja nicht zu meinem Körper dabei. Ach so meinst du das? Du willst mir
eigentlich nur recht geben, oder? Dann habe ich das falsch verstanden. Ich glaube, du willst mir
einfach nur recht geben, dass Pedale mit ein bisschen Abstand nice sind, anstatt seine Füße
rumzuschieben. Ich warte erst mal ab, bis Winter ist. So, also, nice, next. Was ist denn das?
Ninja Air... Hat das irgendwas mit Ninja zu tun? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Das Ding heißt einfach nur
so. Nein, hat kein Stirnband rum. Der Ninja Airfryer. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch so ein
Ding, was einfach abfuck zu reinigen ist, weil es komplett voll geölt ist überall. Ne, so was
brauche ich nicht. Was geht hier? Moin, Patrick. Ich kaufe Dinger, die ich eigentlich off-stream
gekauft hätte, aber jetzt on-stream kaufe. Aber schön, dass du da bist. 51 Monate Hypersubscription.
So, was brauche ich denn als nächstes? Oh, ich brauche natürlich, ich brauche natürlich was
ganz Belangloses noch, fällt mir gerade so ein. Und zwar, ich brauche so ein Fünferpack T-Shirts.
So was hier im Prinzip, so was. Okay, XXXL ist vielleicht a busy feel. Ja, so, sag mal XL. XL
ist okay, das reicht. Ja, und, und, warum gibt es eigentlich keine Farbauswahl da unten? Ja,
und, und ich brauche welche in... Sind die nicht einfach in Weiß? Gibt es nicht einfach fünf
Stück in Weiß? Warum ist das so eine komische Mischung? Ach hier, Weiß. 18 Euro. Und wie viel
kosten fünf? Was, Notizblock? Was ist das für eine komische Kombination? Fünfer Grau plus ein
Notizblock? Das kommt jetzt komplett random einfach nur, dass da ein Notizblock dabei ist. Kriege ich
nicht, kriege ich nicht einfach fünf Stück in Weiß? Naja, gibt es nicht. Ist outdated, overrated,
okay, Kackbraun brauche ich auch nicht. Oliven, ich will keinen Notizblock. Geht weg. Ich kriege
aber immer Notizblock dabei. Okay, man kriegt immer Notizblock, keine. Okay, das ist gut. Zwei,
zwei Weiße, zwei Schwarze. Aber einfach Weiß ist nur eins und es kostet 18 Euro. Das ist ja,
das ist ja viel zu teuer. Das sind, das ist ein, ne, sind es fünf? Oder ist es jetzt eins? Ich meine,
da sind fünf abgebildet. Es sind immer fünfer Pack. Okay, fünfer Pack, sehr gut. Fünfer Pack,
weiße T-Shirts, zack. So, und wie sehen die blauen aus? Blue Navy, Blue Royal, ne, Blue Navy.
Oh, bam. So, T-Shirts. Nicht einloggen. Die passen auch ganz gut, von denen habe ich schon
ein paar. Sehr schön. T-Shirts. Chat, ich sehe ja, ein paar von euch sind auch begeisterte
Fahrradfahrer. Moritz, danke schön für den Sub. Ich habe dir übrigens was weitergeleitet. Eine
Sponsoring-Abfrage von HelloFresh. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das lohnt, ob das was taugt. Aktuell mache
ich ja relativ wenig. Aber HelloFresh, die wären bei mir richtig, weil, wenn es um Food geht.
Dankeschön, by the way, für den Sub. 41 Monate. Subscription. Leute im Marketing haben nie frei.
Nudeln mit Lachs jeden Tag. Ja, das schreibe ich auch an HelloFresh. Ich schreibe an HelloFresh,
ja. Also für die erste Sponsoring-Woche würde ich gerne jegliche Variationen von Nudeln mit
Lachs von euch bekommen. So ist das. Das ist das richtige Work-Life-Balance-Mindset. Und immer bei
Rückfragen sagen, da sind wir dran. Das ist eh die ultimative Antwort. Ich nehme das mit und dann
sind wir dran. Und dann kann man sie immer mit rausreden. Oder wir haben das auf dem Radar,
ist auch nicht schlecht. Aber da sind wir dran, ist gut. Da sind wir dran. Und wenn es eng wird,
sagt er, da sind wir mit Hochdruck dran. Kann das ja immer noch ein bisschen steigern. Da
arbeiten wir mit höchster Priorität ab. Oh, der Hype-Train ist am Start. Wo kommt der auf einmal
her? Wesos muss ins Weltall. Keck-Business-Time. So, also was brauche ich denn als nächstes,
Chat? Habe ich die Kamera schon reingemacht? Nicht die Kamera, die, die Kamera, Alter. Das
Rück-, das Radar, ja, habe ich schon. Übrigens, Chat, jetzt war, jetzt war wirklich, seriously,
Keck-Weight. Ernste Frage, Leute. Keck-Weight. Ich, ich brauche jetzt mindestens fünf Keck-Weights
im Chat, dass ich weiterreden kann. Serious-Time. Jungs, dankeschön für den Sub. Huge Subscription.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier. Okay, nice. Also, weiter geht's. Genug Keck-Weights. Serious-Time. Soll
ich mir eine GoPro kaufen? Und dass ich ab und zu mal Video-Footage im Hintergrund laufen lassen
kann, wo ich einfach nur sinnlos durch den Wald fahre? Weil ich brauche irgendwas für meine Videos
im Hintergrund. Und ja, natürlich, ich kann irgendwelche Boomer-Shooter-Gameplays nehmen,
überhaupt kein Problem. Aber ab und zu mal, ab und zu mal irgendwie sowas, ich renne durch den Wald
oder ich fahre mit dem Fahrrad durch den Wald oder über das Feld. Wäre doch auch mal nicht
verkehrt, oder? Nee, Handys sind da nicht so geil. Was kostet denn eine aktuelle GoPro und wie heißt
das aktuelle GoPro-Modell überhaupt? Die haben ja irgendwie 500 verschiedene. New. Hero 12 Black.
Black Bones. Okay, es gibt 10 Black, 11 Black, 12 Black. Das ist ja fast schon Microsoft-Level
von Produktbenahmungen. Xbox 360 One, Xbox X, Xbox One S. Also, ich vermute mal, dass die Hero
12 Black die neueste ist. Jetzt ist halt die Frage, ist das einfach nur die neueste und im
Prinzip ein neuer Aufguss von der 11er und die 11er war ein Aufguss von der 10er? Oder ist das
eher sowas wie bei Garmin? Garmin 140, 540, 840. 1040. Schau mal, wie heißt das Ding? Osmo Action
4. Und warum ist die besser als GoPro? Ich habe echt gar keinen Plan. Die Zahlen ist die Generation,
aha. Fazit, Fazit.
Also, ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung davon, was da jetzt gut ist. Also, ich bin da so der komplette
Noob. Das Einzige, was ich weiß, ist, dass halt so generell GoPro sich den Namen gemacht hat mit
so Action-Cams, weil das halt einer der erstgroßen war. Das heißt natürlich nicht, dass das die
Besten sind. Was ich ganz gut finde, das gucken wir doch einfach mal nach Features. Was ich ja
ganz gerne hätte, wenn ich mir so, Moment, GoPro Subscriber? Warum, die wollen nicht ernsthaft,
dass ich subscribe, dass ich meine Kamera benutzen kann, oder? Die wurden überholt. Okay, dann erklär
doch mal, so dass ich, was kann beispielsweise ein anderer Hersteller besser? Oder sagen wir,
umgedreht. Es kann auch nur der Preis sein, die können alles gleich gut, aber sind billiger.
Wahrscheinlich, für das, was ich machen will, ist wahrscheinlich, egal. Akkulaufzeiten, sehr
guter Punkt, Chatge, sehr guter Punkt. Akkulaufzeiten GoPro. GoPro-Akkulaufzeiten. Okay, die GoPro-Website
suckt schon mal. Habt ihr das gesehen gerade? Es ist, es ist, es ist, alter, es ist statischer,
poplicher, statischer HTML-Content, Mann. Warum lädt das fünf Sekunden? Was ist das? Guckt euch
das mal an. Schrott-Webseite, Alter. Nicht blazingly fast, written in Rust. Mit Rust wäre
das nicht passiert. Rust-Backend, Rust-Web-Assembly-Frontend, easy, blazingly fast. So,
was haben wir denn hier für Zeiten? Hyper-Smooth-Ein. Also, das ist wahrscheinlich irgend so ein,
ja, wie nennt man das so, dieses Anti-Shaking-Ruckel-Algorithmus-Zeug. Das ist wahrscheinlich,
wenn man vom Fahrrad aufnimmt, gar nicht so schlecht. Das sind aber schon ganz schön kurze
Akkulaufzeiten, ne? Ich meine, mit 30 FPS muss man da nicht mehr um die Ecke kommen. Ich denke,
in der heutigen Zeit ganz gut dürften wahrscheinlich, wenn man, wenn man auf Akkuzeit
Wert, Wert legt, 1080p, 60 FPS sein. Ja. Wenn es Hintergrund-Zeitraffer werden soll, weiß ich,
ob ich Zeitraffer mache. Ich würde wahrscheinlich dann einfach so ein paar Abschnitte zusammen und
so. Das menschliche Auge, das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Das Auge sieht nur 12 FPS, aber du hast
zwei, deswegen kommst du auf 24. Nicht immer so Falschinformationen verbreiten hier, Chat. Fake
News. Zwölf pro Auge. So, also ich denke mal, 1080p, 60 FPS klingt doch ganz gut. 4K60. Okay,
und wie, und wie heißt das andere Ding, nach dem ich gucken sollte? Ist das Action 4 oder so? Das
Ding? Action 4 Akkulaufzeit? So viel besser ist es ja auch nicht. Machen wir, machen wir mal,
machen wir mal was anderes. Battery life. Okay, das hält ein bisschen länger. Okay,
4K120 FPS nach 70 Minuten. Na, dann sind die, dann ist der Unterschied wahrscheinlich in der
Realität gar nicht so groß. Die eine hält eine Stunde 45 und die andere zweieinhalb Stunden und
unter realen Bedingungen halten beide wahrscheinlich nur eineinhalb. Okay,
guck mal mal. Versus, versus GoPro. Von denen hört man weniger. Weniger hören ist wahrscheinlich
besser. Ja, Powerbanks, die musst du halt auch auf dem Fahrrad mitschleppen. Für mich reicht
der eineinhalb Stunden Akkulaufzeit komplett aus. Ich meine, ich fahre, ich fahre länger als
eineinhalb Stunden, aber ich würde dich halt einfach immer mal ein- und ausschalten so.
Wisst ihr was? Ich bestelle mir einfach mal eine GoPro und dann gucken wir mal. Was kostet,
was kostet sowas aktuell? Bei der, auf der GoPro Webseite stand glaube ich 399 Dollar. What? Okay,
das sind die Ami-Preise ohne, ohne Mehrwertsteuer und sowas wieder. 450 Euro. Das ist halt wieder
so ein Punkt. Es ist nicht so, dass ich es mir nicht leisten könnte, aber ich weiß nicht,
ob ich das will. Ach komm, scheiß drauf. Irgendwo muss die Kohle hin. Irgendwann kratze ich ab. Was
will ich mit der ganzen Kohle machen? Gemischte Ein- und große Probleme mit Streuläuch. Rock
Solid und super Bildqualität. Ja, wir gucken mal Preisvergleich. Tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht.
Wir gucken mal bei Geizhals. Der Katzegehe. So ein großer Unterschied ist es jetzt. Ebay. Ja,
geil. Ebay. Bei? Warum sieht Geizhals auf einmal so komisch aus? Ah, hier. Ebay. Bei VE Rareware.
Es könnte wenigstens VIM Rareware sein. Cam4Pro. Fotoerhard. Kossel. Fotoerhard. Ganz ehrlich,
für den Preis kaufe ich lieber direkt bei Amazon. Nee, nee, Max, ich kaufe mir selbst
einen. Aber danke für das Angebot. Ach komm, scheiß drauf. Bam. Nur mal gucken,
wie ich die am Fahrrad montieren kann, aber da lasse ich mir irgendwas anderes dazu einfallen.
Gibt es denn vielleicht einen GoPro Garmin Adapter? Ja, sowas hier wäre natürlich nice. Dann könnte
ich anstatt meinem Garmin die GoPro drauf machen, wenn ich aufnehmen will. Wobei ja noch cooler,
noch cooler wäre es ja, wenn es einen Adapter für den Lenker gäbe, wo ich oben meinen Garmin drauf
machen kann und unten dran oder umgedreht irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die GoPro dranhängen. Kommt die
GoPro mit einem Fahrradmount? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Die lassen sich wahrscheinlich jeden Furz
extra bezahlen, oder? Nee, auf Helm werde ich die GoPro nicht mounten. Wo hast du deinen Garmin?
Vorne am Lenker. In der Mitte. Am offiziellen Garmin Halter. Alter, ich mach keinen Helmmount.
Druck doch selber einen halt. Das ist eine exzellente Idee, muss ich sagen. Exzellent,
Pfeiffer-Time-Chat. Das ist eine sehr gute Idee. Da kann ich meinen 3D-Drucker wenigstens mal für
was Sinnvolles verwenden. Wobei. Okay, das ist das, was mitgeliefert wird, oder? Dieser Stecker
und dieses, oder? Was davon wird mitgemount? Was davon wird mitgeliefert? Ich finde,
das ist eine gute Idee. Thingiverse. GoPro-Bike-Mounts. Oder eigentlich mal Bicycle
nennen die es ja immer. Ja, gibt es ein paar. Ja, das kann ich theoretisch auch selbst 3D
drucken. Finde ich eigentlich ganz cool. Das passt so an meine Aero-Lenker auf jeden Fall nicht dran.
Da brauche ich ein bisschen was anders geformtes mit ein paar bisschen Gummi drunter. Mal gucken.
Ich bin mir da noch nicht so sicher. Alter, was ist hier los? Sind die Druckvorlagen kostbar?
Thingiverse, ja, ist alles kostenlos. Lenkerhalterung. Gibt es da auch irgendwas,
was normal aussieht? Ah, da muss ich mir mal Gedanken zu machen. Da weiß ich jetzt aktuell
nicht so genau, was ich da mache. Wie wäre es damit? Das Problem ist, das kannst du noch
nirgendwo ans Fahrrad festmachen. Da fehlt ja das eigentliche Stück für den Lenker. Moment,
Moment. Ernsthaft? So blöd es aussieht, ich glaube, es ist gar nicht so doof. Weil,
mal angenommen, du willst dich wirklich aufnehmen beim Skifahren. Ja, wo willst du die Kamera denn
hinmachen, dass sie gut positioniert ist? Mundhalterung. So dumm es aussieht, ich glaube,
so dumm ist das gar nicht. Atemgeräusche. Ja gut, es macht ja nicht jeder mit Original-Sound,
sondern machen auch was drunter. Gar keine schlechte Idee. Das muss ich mir mal durch
den Kopf gehen lassen. Fällt mir jetzt aktuell nicht ein, wie ich das am besten mache. Also,
eine GoPro kann ich mir mal bestellen, aber eine Halterung für den Lenker und so,
muss ich nochmal gucken. Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Wenn du damit aufs Maul fällst,
dann hast du... Ja gut. Wobei, sag das mal gar nicht, wenn du den Mund fest zu hast,
könnte dir das vielleicht sogar den Arsch retten, je nachdem, ob du auf Steine oder irgendwas drauf
fällst oder nicht. Das ist gar nicht... Ich meine... Ja, sowas. Das sieht ein bisschen aus,
wie der Garmel. Sowas in der Richtung brauche ich, genau. Ja, sowas in der Richtung. Nicht umsonst,
dass es beim Boxen einen Mundschutz gibt. Gut, der Mundschutz guckt dir halt nicht mit der Kamera
aus dem Maul raus. Ja, das stimmt schon. Hast du über eine 360-Kamera nachgedacht? Nee,
glaube ich kommt auch nicht so gut, oder? Sieht anstrengend aus, 360-Kameras zuzugucken. Also,
ich habe aktuell fürs Fahrrad, ich habe mir eine bestellt, nur eine hinten, für vorne bin ich... Ja,
vorne. Habt ihr eine Empfehlung für Licht vorne? Habt ihr eine Empfehlung für ein gutes Licht vorne?
Weil da brauche ich noch eins. Für hinten habe ich jetzt eins, das ich bestellt habe. Sigma. Ist
das nur für Gigachats? Aura 80. Ist das mit Akku? Ach, USB zum Laden. Ja gut. Wobei, jetzt mal
ernsthaft. Hat Garmin eine Frontlampe? Weil ich habe schon das Garmin-Rücklicht. Das kann man
über den Fahrradcomputer steuern. Haben die nicht vielleicht einfach eine Frontlampe? Garmin-Lampe?
150 Euro, Alter! Ja, irgendwann ist ja mal gut. Ich meine, das Ding hier ist Licht und ein Radar
im Hintergrund. Aber für eine popelige Lampe 150 Euro? Ne. Was ist denn das? Drahtlose Rückfahrkamera
mit Nachtsicht. Okay, alles klar. Das ist eher was fürs Motorrad oder sowas. Nix, nix. Ah ne,
fürs Auto sogar. Ne, ne. Oder fürs Motorrad? Ja, für was ist denn das jetzt eigentlich? Ne,
hier. Ich habe da mal eine doofe, doofe Frage jetzt. Der Monitor ist doch gar nicht dabei,
oder? Oder ist da der Monitor dabei? Oder ist das hier der Monitor? Ich checke gerade nicht,
wie das funktionieren soll. Wenn man das irgendwie aufs Handy bekommen würde, okay,
das würde ich noch verstehen. Aber so aktuell verstehe ich die Technik nicht, wenn ich ehrlich
bin. Ich meine, fürs Fahrrad ist das eh nix. Aber trotzdem, es leuchtet mir gerade nicht ein,
wie das funktionieren soll. Okay, da kommt ein Monitor mit. Gibt es diesen Monitor auch
irgendwo mal als einzelnes Bild, sodass man sich angucken kann, wie man das mountet oder so?
Ja, wie mountet man denn diesen Monitor gescheit? Wow! Ne. Moment, man braucht einen Garmin Navi
dafür, dass das funktioniert. Ja gut, das ist ziemlich unsinnig. Also könnte man es,
könnte man das irgendwie anzeigen lassen auf dem Fiat, eingebauten Display vom Fiat,
dann wäre das Pog, aber das geht garantiert nicht. Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken,
finde ich eigentlich ganz... Ja, okay, man braucht, man braucht einen Garmin Navi. Ja,
ja. Ja, das ist, das ist natürlich, das ist natürlich blöd. Ich suche da mal einfach
danach Fiat 500 E. Und das irgendwie verbinden kann, wahrscheinlich nicht. Ne,
das ist nur was für Garmin Navis. Ja, das ist natürlich unsinnig dann. Könnte man,
könnte man das mit einer Smartphone, könnte man das irgendwie, sagen wir mal,
über Carplay übertragen oder so, wäre das ganz nice. Ein Fiat 500 E braucht keine Rückfahrtkamera,
doch. Rückfahrtkamera ist extremely nice. Ja, das geht nur, geht nur für Garmin Sachen. Ja,
dann ist es ziemlich unsinnig. Naja gut, so. Also, wie sind wir jetzt überhaupt dahin gekommen? Ach
so, von dieser überteuerten Lampe. Ne, ich konnte nichts ankreuzen beim Bestellen. Ich
hätte selbstverständlich, also hätte ich mir einen bestellt mit Feature-Auswahl, hätte ich
selbstverständlich eine Rückfahrtkamera genommen. Aber ich habe ja das Vorführauto genommen,
weil es lieferbar war und billiger war. Und er hatte keine. Der hat nur Sensoren. Es gibt die
Möglichkeit, das mit Third-Party-Sachen nachzurüsten. Da habe ich mich aber noch nicht
dran getraut, weil man dort die Display-Unit abschrauben muss, um an die Kabel dranzukommen.
Das sah durchaus machbar aus, aber ich habe vom Autorumschrauben keine Erfahrung. Das ist
Fiat, wenn man das alles haben will. Wenn man das nicht alles haben will, dann nicht. Stimmt,
Frontlicht war aber gewesen. Hast du noch Garantie drauf? Ja. War ja ganz normaler Kauf beim,
beim, beim, beim, beim, beim Autoverkäufer. So, also das, das Ding ist schon mal nice. Gucke
mal. Ich kaufe mir doch im Leben nicht, also jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, so cool das ist,
das Frontlicht beispielsweise über das Navi ein- und ausschalten zu können. Aber ey,
jetzt mal seriously. Ich gebe doch keine 140 Euro aus, wenn ich, wenn ich eins kriege für 40,
was auch komplett den Zweck erfüllt. Ich meine, ich werde das eh nicht standardmäßig dran lassen.
Ich werde das in irgendeine Satteltasche, wo ich übrigens auch noch brauche, in irgendeine
Satteltasche machen. Und wenn ich wirklich mal bei Nebel, Dunkelheit, wie auch immer,
dann mache ich das dran. Ansonsten aber nicht. Chat, was habt ihr sonst noch empfohlen? Giga
Chat Aura 80, Supernova. Der Name klingt ja schon. Fahrradlicht. What the fuck? 270 Euro.
Ne, das stimmt nicht, dass das Licht immer dran sein muss. Du brauchst nur ein Licht dran,
wenn es die Sichtverhältnisse erfordern. Was dran sein muss, ist Frontreflektor, Rückreflektor,
an den Speichenreflektoren, Reflektoren an den Pedalen. Zwei unabhängige Bremsen. Und was habe
ich noch vergessen? Ich glaube, das war es. Lichter brauchst du nur, wenn es die Verhältnisse,
die Lichtverhältnisse erfordert. Wieso weiß man sowas? Weil ich mir das angeguckt habe,
als ich mein Fahrrad ausgestattet habe. Also das erscheint mir noch etwas, etwas teuer. Was
habt ihr geschrieben? Cat Eye gibt es da sonst noch? Moment, hat es einen Reflektor eingebaut?
Das wäre natürlich richtig Giga Chat. Also Chat, hat es einen Reflektor eingebaut? K1580? Alter,
was? Was ist K1580? Warum sieht das so komisch aus, das Licht? Das sieht irgendwie aus,
als hat es einfach ein Loch vorne. Ja, zu meiner Schulzeit war das noch so, aber das hat sich,
das wurde etwas angepasst vor zwei oder drei Jahren. Das ist etwas realistischer geworden.
Du kannst beispielsweise jetzt auch Rücklichter mit Bremsfunktion benutzen und sowas. Eine was?
Eine Fresnel-Linse. Das sagt, dass es den Gegenverkehr nicht blendet. Ja,
naja, was auch immer. Es ist eh nicht lieferbar. Also ich muss sagen, die Giga Chat Lampe sah mir
bisher am sympathischsten aus hier. Sigma Aura 80. Moment, Aura 100 gibt es auch noch,
die ist noch heller oder wie? Die kostet aber einfach das Doppelte. So, hier. 80 USB. Wie
lang? Ich will erstmal kurz checken. Akkulaufzeiten oder sowas. 4 Lightmodes und Lichtstärke.
Battery charge indicator. Man lädt es über USB. Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie USB-C,
aber so richtig erkennt man es nicht. Chat, was meint ihr, was das ist? Es könnte auch
Mikro-USB sein. Mikro-USB, neee. In der heutigen Zeit Mikro-USB. Cagweight. Das sind Lampen ohne
permanentes Clip-In-Mount. Ist doch nicht schlimm. Ich will die eh nicht dranlassen. Könnte ich die
nicht einfach nehmen, in meine Satteltasche packen und wenn ich es brauche, an Clipsen
oder an Gurten, an Lenker und dann ist gut. Ich will ehrlich gesagt die Lampe gar nicht
permanent gemountet haben vorne dran. Moment, die ist nicht wasserfest. Das ist natürlich
schon mal kacke. Also gerade wenn es ein bisschen neblig, regnerisch ist, dann braucht man das ja.
Du wirst, kommt auf den Link an, ob du gebannt wirst oder nicht. Wenn du was zum Thema postest,
dann nicht. Sparsam sorgt 400, äh nicht 400, 4 Stunden im Standby-Modus, 5 Stunden im Mid-Modus,
6,5 im Low-Modus und 15 im Eco-Modus. IPX4-Standard. Das heißt nur Staub, Moment,
ne Moment, wie ist das? Okay, IPX-Rating 4. Device can face only light water splashes. Ja,
das ist ja auch okay. Ich will das ja nicht untertauchen. Was ist der Unterschied zu der hier?
Keine Ahnung, andere Hersteller. Ja, das klingt doch gar nicht so verkehrt, das Ding. Was mich
jetzt noch interessieren würde ist, wie gut der Akku ist, also sprich, wie ist so die Selbstentladung,
weil ich habe das wahrscheinlich eh 90% der Zeit in der Satteltasche und ich feiere eigentlich so
gut wie nie. Also ich werde das ab und zu mal rausholen. Vielleicht wäre es aus Selbstentladungsgründen,
vielleicht wäre es aus Selbstentladungsgründen auch gar nicht so verkehrt, was mit Batterien
zu nehmen, Leute. Okay, was bin ich, was, was, was bin ich da sehend? Was soll mir der Link jetzt?
Fahrradhalterung, Taschenlampe. Ach, so meinst du, dass man eine Taschenlampe drauf macht? Also,
ich habe eine Taschenlampe, aber das ist so eine ultra, so eine ultra helle, ja, wie nennt man das,
so Tactical, Tactical Light heißt das ja, glaube ich, die Umgangssprache nicht so schön. Das wird
mega warm und ist nach, fragt mich nicht, keine Ahnung, nach 45 Minuten ist die Batterie leer.
Also das ist nix, was ich um Fahrrad bräuchte. Die Idee ist aber nicht schlecht. Warum hat der Typ
seinen Frontreflektor am Lenker so rechts? Ja, ja, stimmt und die Pläne, dass sie im Zweifelsfall
auch mit der Lampe läuten, das scheint mir tatsächlich nicht so sinnvoll zu sein. USB
Frontscheinwerfer. Lighthammer 80, der Name allein schon, man. Also, bevor ich jetzt eine
Wissenschaft draus mache, Leute, ich finde, das hier klingt gar nicht so übel, das Teil. Das
lege ich jetzt mal in den Einkaufswagen, bevor wir da jetzt noch drei Stunden mit der Lampe rum
machen. Entlädt sich nicht, merkbar, okay. Dann, dann mal ausprobieren, mal ausprobieren. Chat,
was ich euch fragen, fragen sollte, Review, nice. Äh, Moment, Fahrradbeleuchtung Info,
das ist doch irgendeine G-Bait-Seite, die, wie, wie heißt das, Link, Link Farming oder so betreibt.
Chat, ihr, ich hab doch hier gesehen, wir haben hier einige interessierte Fahrradfahrer am Start.
Benutzt ihr so Arschcreme, so, so spezielle Reibungs-Popo-Creme oder was haltet ihr davon?
Ja, es gibt so Anti-Anti-Reibungs-Anti-Entzündungs-Popo-Creme. Nur bei sechs
Stunden plus, okay. Fokus, Fokus. Ion-Protect Hautschutzcreme. Also, also ich muss sagen,
ich bin ja erst jetzt, ich bin ja erst mit dem neuen Fahrrad, wirklich, ich habe jetzt zweimal
auf dem neuen Fahrrad gesessen und mir tat jetzt der ganze Tag übelste Bobbesweh, aber ich muss
sagen, also, wenn ich mich jetzt hinsetze, ja, ich merke es. Ich merke jetzt auch zum ersten Mal
so richtig in meinem Leben gefühlt oder seit 20 Jahren mal wieder, wo ich meine Knochen im
Bobbes hab, ja, aber es ist schon echt ganz gut mittlerweile. Also, ich denke mal spätestens
morgen oder alles spätestens morgen Mittag ist wahrscheinlich auch wieder gut. Chat, was, was,
was findet ihr besser? Zuerst rennen und dann später am Tag Fahrrad fahren oder zuerst Fahrrad
fahren und dann später rennen? Oder direkt Hardcore direkt nacheinander? Erst Rad, dann Rennen. Okay.
Wie viele Kilometer fährst du am Tag? Nicht der Rede wert. Schwimmen, nein, Schwimmen fange ich
bestimmt nicht an. Auch wenn ich früher, früher war Schwimmen eigentlich mein Lieblingssport, ja.
Also, was ich jetzt gefahren habe, ist, wie gesagt, ich habe das Fahrrad seit dieser Woche Dienstag.
Ich bin jetzt, ich bin jetzt gefahren gestern und vorgestern einmal 25, einmal 32 Kilometer und
habe festgestellt, okay, ich muss mich erst noch an meinen Bobbes, muss ich erst noch an den Sattel
gewöhnen. Also, morgen ist auf jeden Fall Rennen dran eigentlich. Wäre theoretisch heute schon dran
gewesen, aber mir war noch irgendwie Oberschenkel mäßig noch nicht so danach. Nein, lese ich nicht.
Na, mal gucken, wie ich das morgen mache. So, was brauche ich denn sonst noch? Lass mal kurz
überlegen. Ah, ich brauche neue. Das wird jetzt relativ easy, da muss man nicht lange gucken.
Was ist denn gerade? Ist das auch teurer geworden, man? Ich finde das Ding zum,
ich muss mich morgens noch mal schnell rasieren, echt praktisch. Ansonsten bin ich ja vor,
na sagen wir mal einem Jahr ungefähr, auch ins Land der Nassrasierer gewechselt. Am Anfang mit
so einem komischen Gillette Systemrasierer und jetzt seit einer ganzen Weile nur noch mit
Rasierhobel. Da hatte ich ja übel Schiss davor am Anfang, weil ich mir gedacht habe, boah,
da kann man sich so easy damit schneiden. Und Leute, ich habe mich noch nicht einmal so richtig,
wie man sich das denkt, geschnitten damit. Was ich natürlich schon gemacht habe, ist beim Rasieren
irgendwie halt, wenn man so nicht gleich in die richtige Richtung erwischt, mal ein bisschen,
aber nicht so dieses Hups zur Seite. Oh, jetzt habe ich mir übelst in die Backe geschnitten,
ist nicht einmal passiert. Wobei ich muss bei mir am Hals halt übelst aufpassen,
weil bei mir, das ist richtig, richtig, richtig Kacke. Das war mir vorher gar nicht so klar,
als ich das alles immer elektrisch gemacht habe oder auch einfach mal gar nicht, wenn ich zu vorn
war. Ich habe hier unten am Hals, das ist übelst random, wie das wächst. Da wächst teilweise was
links, teilweise was rechts, teilweise was schräg, weil wahrscheinlich nach oben. Alter,
ich muss immer mindestens da, wenn es richtig ordentlich sein soll, dreimal drüber rasieren,
in alle Richtungen, dass es weg ist. Aber das kann ich nicht, weil das irgendwie so ein bisschen
uneben und unempfindlich ist, dass es, wenn ich beim zweiten Mal schon nicht mega aufpasse,
anfängt an manchen Stellen zu bluten. Das heißt, das ist echt ein bisschen, also mein Hals ist
ein bisschen Kacke zu rasieren. Deswegen, ich gehe einfach nächste Woche, ich gehe einfach nächste
Woche, Mittwoch ist glaube ich wieder Arbeitstag, gehe ich einfach mal in Frankfurt wieder zum
Friseur, zum türkischen Friseur, lasse mir Haare schneiden und dann kann man auch gleich Bart
schnippeln und rasieren. Dann muss ich mir selbst keine Gedanken drum machen, dass ich mich schneide.
Montag ist Arbeitstag, ja aber nicht für mich. Was war die Frage, Chat, was ich habe? Ah, du meinst
Rasierhobel, das kann ich dir sagen. Ich habe auch nicht gedacht, dass wir mal über dieses Thema und
Stream reden. Ich habe einen, ich gucke mal kurz an, wie das Ding hieß, Amazon. So einen Teil habe
ich, Moment. Lass mich gerade mal das hier machen. Was ist ein Preis, leistungsmäßig am besten 11 pro
Stück, 7,57 pro Stück, ja dann nehme ich die hier. Der Ersatzklingel reicht doch erst mal, zack. Ich habe
ein, wie heißt das Ding hier, haben wir es doch, Mühle R98 Double Edge Safety Razor. Okay, muss
egal nach was man sucht hier. Das Teil, ist der das? Ist das das Teil? Ja, genau. Ja, das Ding habe
ich. Das ist halt auch so ein unkaputtbares Teil. Ist halt einfach ein Stück Metall. Und die Klingen
sind halt auch mega billig. Also das muss man das echt sagen. Der, das ist, also Preis-Leistung ist
wirklich ein riesen Vorteil von diesen Dingern. Die Rasierklingen sind halt sportbillig. Ich habe
mir einen 100er Pack gekauft. Ich habe mir einen 100er Pack gekauft für, ich gucke gerade mal gerade
bei Amazon, für 8,90. Das hat, da bin ich jetzt quasi so, sind das nächste, nächsten zwei Jahre
oder so mit versorgt. Locker, locker. Ich meine so eine Rasierklinge kannst du, ja, fünf, sechs
mal kannst du die denke ich schon ganz, wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein bisschen öfters, je nachdem wie
viel man schnippelt und wie oft damit. Fünf, sechs mal kannst du die auf jeden Fall benutzen. Und das
also, das hält, das hält schon mal zwei Jahre, wenn ich mich jeden Tag rasieren würde, was ich
nicht mache. Also hält, hält diese 100er Packung hält wahrscheinlich drei Jahre oder so. Welche
klingen, weiß ich nicht, habe ich jetzt gerade auch wieder zugemacht in Amazon. Weiß ich nicht, keine
Ahnung, Moment, ich guck, ja. Astra Razorplates, Astra Razorplates, 100er Pack. Ja, 46.000-fach
approved, Leute. Superior, Platinium, Double Edge, Fertigschaum oder Seife? Ich habe Seife. Ich hatte
ganz am Anfang hatte ich Fertigschaum und ich mochte, mochte das nicht. Hatte mehrere Gründe. Erstens
hatte ich den Eindruck, der Schaum hat den Bart gar nicht richtig, ja, wie nennt man das, rasier-ready
gemacht. Der wurde, der wurde überhaupt nicht, überhaupt nicht richtig nass und weich mit, mit dem
Fertigschaum. Ja und, und noch was, auch eine Sache, die mir nicht gefallen hat. Ich hatte den Eindruck, wenn
man sich ein bisschen geschnitten hat aus Versehen oder wenn man, wenn man selbst, wenn es vielleicht sogar
noch ein bisschen eine Stufe vorm Schneiden ist, es kommt ja manchmal vor, dass es ein bisschen rot ist,
dass ich dann den Eindruck hatte, wenn ich dort drüber rasiert habe, nochmal zum, zum ordentlich
machen, mit, mit dem, mit dem, mit dem Fertigschaum, dass es danach mehr gebrannt hat, als mit Seife.
Seife hat irgendwas Beruhigendes und dieses, und dieses, dieser Fertigschaum hat, hat eher, eher, hat es
noch mehr gebrannt danach. Also ganz ehrlich, ich habe Seife zum Anrühren. Ich habe mir mal so ein
Viererpack Seife gekauft mit irgendwie vier unterschiedlichen, wie nennt man das, es sind nicht
Geschmacksrichtungen, unterschiedliche Duftrichtungen und ich bin immer noch bei der ersten Seife.
Das hält auch gefühlt ewig, das Zeug. Ja, ich habe, ich habe mir so einen Stift gekauft, wobei ich ehrlich
gesagt sagen muss, so geil finde ich das nicht, außer dass es brennt als Fuck. Gibt ja manche Leute, selbst
wenn es nicht blutet oder so, fahren die sich da irgendwie gefühlt noch danach einmal noch komplett
drüber. Das mache ich nicht, ich mache einfach ein bisschen kaltes Wasser und fertig. Wenn man aufpasst,
wie gesagt, bei mir beim Hals muss ich auch aufpassen, das wächst echt in alle Richtungen. Wenn man ein
bisschen aufpasst und das, dass das langsam macht, nicht so wie es manche Videotutorials. Ich habe, Leute, wie
gesagt, ich bin fast 40, bin 39 jetzt. Ich habe mich mein Leben lang nicht nass rasiert, ja, bis jetzt, bis
vor einer Weile und da habe ich mir Tutorials angeguckt und da gibt es, es gibt ja jede Menge How-to-Rasier-Videos
auf YouTube und da hast du Leute, die stellen sich da vor den Spiegel und machen gefühlt mit einem, mit
einem Rasierhobelzug von der Backe bis runter zum Hals und ich denke mir so, Alter, wenn ich das in der
Geschwindigkeit mache, dann, dann reiße ich mir alle Unebenheiten irgendwie weg oder so. In der Geschwindigkeit
kriege ich das nicht hin. Ich muss das, ich muss das schön, ich muss das schön langsam und ordentlich machen und
dann blutet auch nix. Vor allem und das habe ich am Anfang auch verkehrt gemacht, aber das sind
wahrscheinlich so Sachen, die jeder für sich lernen muss. Es bringt nix, wenn man sein Bart da schön
einpinselt, sondern man muss das dann auch mal fünf Minuten einfach drauf lassen, dass das schön
durchweichen kann. Gerade wenn man nicht jeden Tag rasiert und dementsprechend vielleicht auch mal ein
bisschen längere Haare hat. Das muss einfach mal ein paar Minuten eingepinselt sitzen bleiben und
also im Gesicht das Zeug. Dann ist der Bart auch schon durch und dann kriegt man das viel, viel
leichter ab. Ja, ich, wie gesagt, ich habe das auch nie gemacht und ich habe, ich habe dann auch jetzt,
den Fehler würde ich nicht sagen, ich war auch so blöd und habe mit so einem, mit so einem Fünffach-Klingen-Rasierer
angefangen. Und das Ding hatte im Vergleich zu dem Rasierhobel, er hat es richtig gesackt. Also ich
habe mich am Anfang nicht getraut, das mit einem Rasierhobel zu machen und jetzt muss ich sagen,
finde ich das deutlich besser als der andere. Aber so sieht's aus. Ja und danach, danach sollte man
sich noch irgendeine Creme drauf schmieren. Also ich habe mir bei Amazon für zum Rasieren habe ich mir,
wie hieß das, Moment, irgendein Balsam oder sowas gekauft. Die Amazon-Suche ist halt mal richtig
kacke, du findest halt hier nichts. Ja, das, das Teil, da habe ich mir eine Flasche von gekauft und das
finde ich auch ganz gut. Das ist recht beruhigend, da cremt man sich einfach ordentlich danach was
drauf, lässt das einziehen und dann ist so gut wie immer alles gut. Da brauche ich keinen, also
ich habe auch so einen Stein, aber den benutze ich nicht gerne. Selbst, selbst wenn man sich mal
irgendwo ein bisschen erwischt hat, kaltes Wasser drauf, kurz warten, bis das, bis das alles trocken
ist und dann eincremen, ordentlich drauf klatschen, einziehen lassen und dann ist, dann ist alles gut.
Aber da muss jeder irgendwas finden, was für ihn passt, ja. Wie gesagt, ich habe, ich habe es,
naja, wann bekommt man, wann bekommt man so die ersten Haare, so mit 14, 15 vielleicht so und ich
bin jetzt 39. Also sagen wir mal, ich habe, runden wir mal auf, ich habe 20 Jahre, bin ich auch nicht
nass rasiert und jetzt erst vor nicht allzu langer Zeit damit angefangen und man muss, man muss ein
paar Sachen ausprobieren. Es gibt da so kein Pauschalding, was bei allen gut funktioniert.
Wie sieht's oben aus? Du meinst, wie viele Haare noch auf dem Kopf sind? Naja, es ist nicht mal so
viel wie vor zehn Jahren. Ich sehe nicht aus wie Prinz, wie heißt der Typ? Nicht Harry, Harry ist
der Junge. Wie heißt er? Prinz William? Oder ist das Prinz William? Ich kenne mich ja mit Adeligen
überhaupt nicht aus. Ich glaube, Prinz William ist das. Der hat ja fast schon keine Haare mehr,
ja und der ist fast so, der ist ziemlich genauso alt wie ich. Also so schlimm ist es bei mir noch
nicht. Ich muss dir ganz ehrlich sagen, ich dachte, ich dachte, das ist das einzig Sinnvolle, was es
gibt, solche Dinger, aber also ich fahre mit dem Hobel jetzt doch besser. Gut, so, dann sind wir
ein bisschen side getrackt. Was brauche ich denn noch? Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Handschuhe
will ich, will ich haben. Fahrradhandschuhe. Jemand, jemand von euch? Massive Five Header
Empfehlung? Also erst mal, erst mal für, wenn es warm ist. Also irgendwie sowas hier mit, mit Fingern
raus. Halt irgendwas gepolstertes, irgendwas gepolstert. Irgendwas mit, irgendwas gepolstert.
Jaja, wenn es warm ist. Ich ziehe das, ich ziehe das nicht an, weil es kalt ist oder so. Ich ziehe
das an, weil ich will, dass ein bisschen, ein bisschen gepolstert ist auf dem Lenker. Ich bin
ja noch nicht so der super Geübte und ich, ich merke es halt richtig so mit Druckstellen an der
Hand. Was, Ganzfinger? Was ist ein Ganzfinger? Achso, ganz, Moment, Moment. Du meinst einfach
ein stinknormaler Handschuh, wie man ihn kennt, ohne Löcher drin. Und du meinst bei Handschuhen,
also bei normalen Handschuhen, dass die touchfähig sind. Ah ja, jetzt verstehe ich es. Ich wollte
ja jetzt eh, solange es noch warm ist, erst mal sowas hier haben. Das ist doch irgendwelche
China-Chinesen Zeug hier, oder? Vom Namen her klingt das alles super China-Chinesen mäßig.
Crip Crap. Ist das auch ein China-Chinesen Ding? Okay, vom Namen her klingt das noch ein bisschen,
aber okay, nein, das ist kein China-Chinesen Ding, oder? Lass mal kurz gucken. Ja, ich,
wie gesagt, mein Fahrrad ist erstens wahrscheinlich noch nicht hundertprozentig richtig eingestellt,
aber trotzdem ein bisschen, wenn du dich vorne festhältst, ein bisschen Polsterung kann ja da
nicht schaden. Ich glaube, bei mir liegt es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so sehr am Lenker. Ich glaube,
der Lenker ist tatsächlich ganz gut eingestellt. Ich glaube, ich muss ein bisschen, ich muss meinen
Sattel ein bisschen hinter machen. Ich hänge einfach viel zu sehr auf dem Lenker drauf. Gut,
wenn du, wenn du danach deine Handschuhe auswählen willst, dann musst du was anderes kaufen.
Einfach Payday 3 spielen anstelle Spanküberfalls und dann nicht spielen können, weil die Server
kaputt sind. Dr. Dr. Dr. Gehl. Na, dein Name ist ja schon mal was, ey. Dr. Gehl. Ich meine,
wenigstens sehen die Typen mal so aus wie ich auf dem Fahrrad hier. Kenn ich,
habe ich schon geguckt. So, komm, in den Einkaufswagen. Was meint größer auswählen?
BXL? Wahrscheinlich ist es viel zu groß für mich. Keine Ahnung. Einkaufswagen, bam. Mal
checken. Das Schöne bei Amazon ist, man kann es ja einfach wieder zurückschicken. So,
habt ihr eine Empfehlung, was Trinkflaschenhalter und sowas angeht? Und Trinkflaschen und
Trinkflaschenhalter? Also, wir gucken jetzt aber erst mal, wir gucken jetzt erst mal nach
Satteltasche. Fitlock. Fitlock-Satteltasche. Ach, sowas hier. Oh, das ist wieder so ein,
das ist wieder so ein Ding, wenn ich das schon sehe. Die sind doch garantiert nur
kompatibel mit ihren eigenen Taschen, oder? Das ist wieder so ein Ding,
so Vendor-Login. So wenig Tabs offen. Moment, Moment, Moment. Was hältst du davon? Und davon,
das ist noch ein bisschen besser. Ich habe jetzt einfach noch ein drittes Fenster offen,
in dem nicht viele Tabs sind. Ach so, für Trinkflaschen. Trinkflasche. 800, 800, 500,
800 Milliliter, okay. Aha. Okay, da hätte ich schon mal eine Frage zu. Clipst man jetzt das
ganze Ding aus, wenn man daraus trinken will? Oder zieht man die Flasche aus dem Halter raus
und lässt es dran geklipst? Du drehst die Flasche raus. Ja, bekommt man die dann überhaupt auch
wieder dran? Weil ich meine, blind im Rahmen sowas anzuschließen, ist doch deutlich komplizierter,
als einfach, als einfach da in den Halter eine Flasche wieder reinstellen. Oder meint ihr,
man gewöhnt sich da dran? Und das ist ein Set aus Halter und Flasche. Ja,
man. Vielleicht nicht unbedingt in Rot. Weiß nicht, das sieht irgendwie nicht so passend aus.
Ich muss ja sagen, ich finde diese Kombi hier gar nicht mal so verkehrt. Du drehst die Flasche
raus, bekommst du die, wie gut bekommst du die wieder dran im Fahren? Wie gesagt, ich bin,
ich bin noch nicht der sicherste Fahrer. Also wenn ich da irgendwie mit einer Hand am Lenker nur
nach unten gucken muss und rumfummeln unter meinem Fahrrad. Also ja, mal gucken. Ich haus
mal in den Warenkorb rein. Aber ich brauche auf jeden Fall eine Satteltasche. Wobei da gab es
doch irgendwie auch was von denen, oder? Aber macht eigentlich keinen Sinn. Warum sollte ich
so ein Clip dafür dran machen? Werkzeugtasche Toolbox. Vielleicht sollte ich mir auch lieber
sowas holen. Ich meine, es muss ja nicht unbedingt eine Satteltasche sein. Wobei Satteltasche ist
schon ist schon schon schon angenehmer. Wie viele Befestigungspunkte hast du am Rahmen? Ich glaube
relativ viele. Moment, hier gab es doch einen Link zum Fahrrad. Ich glaube gar nicht so. Also
hier sind welche. Da sind welche. Dann hat man hier oben weiß ich nicht, da erkennt man es nicht
richtig. Aber vermutlich da auch. Und wenn man Sicherheitsbleche und irgendwie Gepäckträger oder
so anbringen will, hat man hier auch irgendwie noch Möglichkeiten. Wisst ihr, was ich ja cool
finde? Weil ich bei manchen Fahrradherstellern gesehen habe, dass die so eine kleine Aussparung
in dem Rohr drin haben, dass man hier beispielsweise eine Luftpumpe rein machen
kann. Vielleicht hat es das auch und das Bild ist einfach nur Pepega. Weiß ich nicht. Wo steht
denn sowas hier? Ausstattung? Wo steht denn hier sowas? Gar nicht, oder? Wahrscheinlich im Handbuch?
Ja. Also zwei Sachen kriegt man auf jeden Fall dran. Ich will gar keine Luftpumpe mitnehmen.
Ich meine, weil es nur ein Beispiel. Ich brauche für meine Reifen gar keine Luftpumpe. Oder höchst
wahrscheinlich keine Luftpumpe. Ja gut. Klar, im Zweifelsfall kann man einfach mit irgendeinem
Klettverschluss oder mit irgendeinem Kabelbinder auch was dran machen. Aber wenn das Montagepunkte
hätte, ist es schon nicer. Aber ich brauche auf jeden Fall irgendeine kleine Satteltasche. Sei
es fürs Handy. Aktuell habe ich so eine Umhänge. Wie nennt man das? So eine Tasche, die man so um
den Bauch klipsen kann und die drehe ich dann einfach auf den Rücken. Ist fast ein bisschen
so wie so eine Trikottasche. Nur dass es halt nicht zum T-Shirt gehört. Aber sowas hier wäre
schon ganz praktisch für Handy, Schlüssel, vielleicht auch irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
Snickers oder so. Wobei Snickers schmilzt. Irgendeinen Riegel, falls man mal was braucht.
Oberrohrtasche ist fürs Handy geil. Du meinst irgendeine Tasche obendrauf mit einer Handyhalterung
oder wie? Also ich habe mein Handy bisher noch nicht gebraucht. Ich habe die Route,
habe ich gesynct aufs Garmin vorher und das hat dann auch funktioniert. Das erscheint mir ein
bisschen fett, ehrlich gesagt. PepoFatTime. Oder das sieht einfach noch viel größer auf
den Bildern aus, als es ist. Aber so eine kleine Satteltasche würde mir eigentlich
kommen. Die hier sieht doch relativ klein aus. Würde mir eigentlich reichen. Hackermans gemacht,
was hast du denn Hackermans? Lass uns teilhaben. Pifeheader, Modge. Ja,
dann weiß ich nicht. Das muss ich mir mal auf Stream angucken. Bin ich mir nicht so,
weiß ich nicht so genau. Also ich habe jetzt drei Hosen mit Polster drin. Das reicht erst mal.
Gucken, welche mir da am liebsten ist von. Ich wollte mal, ich habe drei verschiedene,
weil ich mal ausprobieren wollte, welche sich da am besten anfühlen. Ja, tatsächlich ist das eine
davon. Ja, eines davon ist eine von Gore. Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob es eine Gore CS5 ist.
Ich kann mal kurz gucken. Wie komme ich auf CS5? Eine Gore 3 steht bei mir dran. Was ist der
Unterschied zwischen 3 und 5? Ist 5 langbeinig oder mit langen Beinen? Ah, das ist die mit
langen Beinen. Ja, die C3 ist die mit kurzen Beinen. So, jetzt sind wir von einer Sache
komplett weggekommen. Ich wollte auch mal noch nach einer Ware gucken. Gibt es denn,
gibt es die Mi Scale Dinger noch zu kaufen? Okay. Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen der,
das sieht übelst cringe aus, diese Dinger auf den Bildern immer. Was ist denn der Unterschied
zwischen der C5 und C3? Ja, hi Uwe. Ich bin der Uwe, ich bin auch dabei. Okay. Okay,
C ist Cycling. Die Passform ist etwas legerer und erhöht die Vielseitigkeit. Ja, das ist genau
das Richtige für mich. Das ist genau das Richtige für mich. Da muss ja mein Bauch reinpassen. Ja,
dann ist doch gut, dass ich die C3 gekauft habe. Ja, aber Waage wollte ich jetzt eigentlich gucken.
Mi Scale. Warum kostet das alles so extrem unterschiedlich? Mi Scale? Scale? Das ist doch
genau die gleiche. Ich glaube, das ist einfach China-Chinesen-Things, wo man nicht checkt.
Warum das unterschiedlich viel? Nee, das ist, das ist die schon. Das ist die schon. Was kosten
bei AliExpress? Moment, warum kostet das bei AliExpress einfach das Doppelte? Was ist da los?
Was ist denn jetzt? Fuck. Warum sind da Löffel? Zusätzlich ein Prozent Rabatt mit Münzen. Okay,
AliExpress, alles klar. Gibt auch eine von Garmin. Aber Garmin kannst du wahrscheinlich wieder nur,
wenn du ein Locked-In hast. Und mein Gewicht hätte ich schon gerne auch irgendwie wieder,
würde ich auch wieder rausbekommen gerne aus dem Ökosystem. Ja, dann kaufe ich mir doch hier eine.
Das ist die gleiche, die ich habe. Da muss ich einfach nichts ändern. 22 Euro gehen auch klar.
Da muss ich einfach nichts ändern. Kann die austauschen durch die Neue und mein ESP32 greift
weiter die Werte ab. Gut ist, fertig, aus. Bäm, eingekauft. Kann man sich doch echt nicht beschweren.
22,44. Top. Wie könnte... Alter, ein Anzeigefehler. Nicht dauerhaft, aber oft genug, dass es mich stört.
Vielleicht... Ich meine, Batterie leer kann eigentlich nicht sein. Die habe ich erst getauscht.
Vielleicht muss ich die einfach mal... Vielleicht muss ich einfach mal draufhauen aufs Display,
dann geht es wieder. Kann auch sein. Das probiere ich auf jeden Fall, bevor ich mir eine neue
bestelle. Ich haue einfach mal auf die Waage drauf und gucke, ob es da wieder geht. Fast
1000 Euro Warenkorb, ja. Ich glaube, das mit Abstand teuerste ist halt einfach die Kamera.
Die kostet dann einfach die Hälfte davon. Der Rest, der Rest ist eigentlich okay für die Katze
und das Radar. Der Rest ist eigentlich preis-leistungsmäßig durchaus okay. Hast du eine
Haltung für die GoPro? Noch nicht. Ich bin auch unschlüssig, wie ich das montieren will. Vielleicht
drücke ich mir auch selbst eine aus. Zum Testen mal. Weiß ich noch nicht genau. Ich glaube,
ich habe alles. Warum T-Shirts für 20 Euro? Das sind 5 Stück für 20 Euro. Ich glaube,
da kann man nichts sagen. Sind das 5 Stück für 18 Euro oder 5 Stück für 19 Euro? Das ist doch
echt okay, oder? Klingel. Ja gut, die habe ich in den Warenkorb geschmissen, um euch die Klingel
zu zeigen. Die habe ich schon. Die brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht mehr. Keine Ahnung.
Ist absoluter Mist. Also, das mag sein. Ich habe da jetzt schon ein paar und die habe ich auch
schon ein paar Jahre und die gehen eigentlich ganz gut. Die sind halt billig, aber da kaufe
ich mir ab und zu mal ein paar neue. Wahrscheinlich ist es egal, was du kaufst. Das ist alles irgendwie
Kinderarbeit aus Bangladesch. Haben die was zwischen den... Ja, guck mal, die haben hier
irgendwas dazwischen. Guck mal, irgendwelche Dinger dazwischen. Was soll das sein? Für was
die GoPro? Ja, dass ich ein bisschen Hintergrund-Video-Material habe, falls ich mal keine
Boomer-Shooter im Hintergrund für YouTube haben will. Da drehe ich einfach mit dem Fahrrad schnell
eine Runde und nehme im Hintergrund was auf und lasse es laufen oder ich rede dann über was
komplett anderes. Stream werden wir damit nicht machen. Kann man überhaupt mit einer GoPro und
Twitch? Ja, kann man, aber ich meine Deutschland und mobiles Internet. Keine Ahnung, wie gut das
funktioniert. Ich glaube, das ist einfach viel zu schlecht. Der Internetempfang, wenn ich da
irgendwie durch den Wald und durchs Feld fahre. Zu was? Starling auf dem Gepäckträger.
Wahlempfang. Ja, es gibt doch nicht viele Möglichkeiten, oder? Ich meine, Mobilfunk,
was willst du machen? Außer du hast irgendwo überall auf der Welt WLAN-Access. In Städten
ist das ja meistens kein Problem, aber ich meine, unterwegs ist halt bestimmt immer mal
zwischendurch halt Verbindungsabbruch und noch viel eher mal kein so guter Empfang. Da kannst
du dann irgendwie mit 500 Kilobit streamen oder so. Das ist dann auch kacke. Da muss ich dann aber
auf jeden Fall meine Sonnenbrille aufsetzen. Nicht, dass mich noch jemand erkennt. Leaked. Also,
was ich machen würde ist, wenn überhaupt. Also, was ich machen werde jetzt, ist, ich nehme ohne
zu streamen auf. Das mit streamen ist Schwachsinn. Das steht eigentlich auch gar nicht zur Diskussion.
Ansonsten habe ich ein Handy dabei und hätte die Kamera dabei. Das reicht ja, sofern das Handy eben
ordentlichen Empfang hat. Ab eine Million Abos leake ich mich. Ja, aber das wird nicht passieren.
Zumindest nicht in sehr, sehr langer Zeit. Eher nie. Ich glaube, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob das Fahrrad so auffällig ist. Es gibt doch bestimmt genug, die rose Fahrräder haben. Holst
du dir das iPhone 15? Nein, das sehe ich nicht ein. Das wäre jetzt auch für mich rausgeschmissenes
Geld. Das Upgrade. Also, mein iPhone 14 wird noch ganz, ganz lange halten. Also,
das wird auch wirklich noch eine Weile halten, bis es keine Updates mehr gibt.
Also, ich habe meiner Mutter ja ein iPhone 11 gekauft. War das ein 11er? Ich glaube ein 11er.
Ungefähr zeitgleich zu meinem iPhone 14. Nee, das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt nicht. Eine ganze
Ecke davor. Und selbst das hält noch ewig. Also, hier gibt es erstmal kein neues iPhone.
Das letzte, was ich gekauft habe, war entweder mein iPhone 14 sogar oder das iPad Pro. Heißen
die Pro? Ich glaube schon. Richtig, so ein richtig großes, nices iPad. Also, für täglich
benutzende Geräte. Ich bin da halt immer ein bisschen hin und her gerissen, was das Apple
Zeug angeht. Auf der einen Seite finde ich die zum täglichen Benutzen wirklich ganz angenehm.
Sobald es ans Basteln geht, ist Android einfach viel angenehmer als Apple. Und was mir bei Apple
halt nervt ist, dass sie dir an jeder Ecke irgendwie ihr Ökosystem unterschieben wollen.
So nach dem Motto, ah, sie haben sich ja nicht mit Cloud verbunden, wollen sie das machen? Hast
dich mit der Cloud verbunden und gleichzeitig werden 15 weitere Services aktiviert. Einfach
nur weil du dich in der Cloud eingeloggt hast. Auf einmal sünden sich alle deine Apps,
was du gar nicht haben willst und sowas. Das fuckt mich ab bei Apple. Also,
ich benutze so wenig von Apple wie möglich auf meinen Apple Geräten. Ja, genau. Die Dinger,
die bei Aliexpress 4,50 Euro oder so kosten und in einem 20er Pack, man sich kaufen kann. Ja,
ich glaube, die waren von diesem Sub-Brand von Xiaomi. Aber wie gesagt, Custom-Firmware-Flashen,
sonst kannst du die vergessen. Also, die habe ich nicht geguckt. Was es nicht bei Amazon gibt,
existiert für mich nicht. Keine Ahnung. Nein, die sind nicht von Aqara, die Thermostate. Oh ja,
muss ich mal gucken. Da weiß ich noch nicht genau, was ich da überhaupt für Anforderungen habe. Da
muss ich mir erst mal Gedanken machen. Okay, Chat, was ist jetzt angesagt? Richtig. Boomer müde
um etwas. Rock Bros. Ach, guck mal hier mit Handy-Halterung vorne drauf. Okay,
das ist eigentlich echt ganz cool sowas. Wenn man denn doch mal aufs Handy gucken muss,
finde ich das gar nicht so blöd. Ich packe mir das mal in den Warenkorb, einfach,
dass ich es nicht vergesse. Und von Nudeln mit Lachs. Ja, gab es heute wieder. Richtig
große Portionen. Also, Leute, wir sehen uns. Macht es gut. Bis dann. C, U.